-So, a lot of people are
saying now that, look,
we basically are down to
two candidates, it seems like.
And everyone's worried,
if one wins,
will the supporters of the other
sort of agree to support
the Democratic nominee?
That's a question
you get asked a lot.
Is it safe to assume
that you will support Joe Bide
if he is the nominee?
-Yeah, you know, I think -
You know, I've said
throughout this entire process
that what is so important
is that we ultimately unit
behind who that
Democratic nominee is,
and I think
it's a two-way street.
I've been concerned
by some folks that say,
if Bernie's the nominee,
they won't support him,
and the other way around.
Right now, November, you know,
this is more important
than all of us,
and we really need to make sur
that we defeat Donald Trum
at the polls.
Assuming and knowing,
how insane it's going to get
between now and then.
-Yeah, it doesn't seem
like this is going to be
a laid-back election season.
-It's not going to be chill, no.
-No, it's not going to be chill.
It's not going to be like,
"Honey, the debate's on.
Let's get a glass of wine.
-Yeah. [ Chuckling ]
-One thing that must be
surreal for you is, 2016,
you knocked on doors
for Bernie Sanders.
-Yeah.
-And then two years later,
you get elected congresswoman.
Now you are actually
on the stump with Bernie.
When you go out on stage
for these giant Bernie rallies
does it seem --
does it seem as surreal to you
that I imagine it does?
-It's completely surreal.
Just, you know, four years ago
I was in the South Bronx,
as a volunteer,
helping organize this massiv
rally in St. Mary's Park,
and at the time,
Bernie Sanders was
one of the first
Democratic candidates
since, I believe,
Robert F. Kennedy
to campaign in the South Bronx
And to have a candidate
that really saw our communit
was really impactful,
and now to be able
to go out and bear witness
to what so many communitie
are experiencing
all across the country
is just very full circle
and gratifying.
-And, obviously, a lot's changed
for you in the four years.
Is it safe to assume
that Bernie hasn't
changed at all?
[ Laughter ]
-I think he's changed
a little bit.
I think he's changed,
although, he is famous
for his consistency.
-I mean, I do think for thos
who are drawn to Bernie,
that is the thing that is
impossible to argue with.
As far as a politician wit
consistency over the years
I mean, he really stands out
-He does, and he's been fighting
for health care as a right
this entire time,
and it's --
You know, now that I'm
on the other side in Congres
and you see how much
pressure there is,
you know, to bow to a lot
of special interests...
The fact that he has been
relying on small-dollar donors
since before the Internet
kind of blows my mind.
It's like collecting littl
checks this whole time
and really committed
to a grassroots movement
when it was way, way harde
than it is even now
is really phenomenal.
-Another thing that will
have huge implications,
not just on this election
but the next decade,
is the census.
Can you speak about
how you're approaching tha
and just try
to explain to people
exactly how important it is.
-So, we are all going to get
census forms or a prompt.
We're all going to get maile
a prompt to fill out the censu
in the next two weeks or so,
and so I think what's
really important is
that we all fill this out.
It happens once every 10 years
Every single person, no matter
your documentation status,
no matter your housing status,
income, et cetera,
is to be counted,
and it determines
how much our schools are
going to get funded,
how much infrastructure
gets invested
and, of course, how many members
of Congress each community gets.
And if you get undercounted,
you know --
In some parts of New York City
some communities,
the self-reporting is
about half of what
we think it should be,
and that has real impacts
on apportionment of,
you know, how many teacher
that your local schools get,
so it's really important.
It's completely confidential
and it's even confidential
within the federal government.
Your census data is not shared
with any other Federal Agenc
at all.
So, don't worry if you're having
a creative living situation.
It's not gonna be
told to your landlord
or anything crazy like that.
Don't worry.
Totally safe.
[ Laughter ]
-A good tip.
A good tip for my viewers.
[ Laughter ]
Hello to the 10 of you
watching together right now.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very happy to see
you got some companionship
for yourself.
-I did.
-I would imagine Washington,
even though it's crowded
with people,
can be very lonely.
You got a new dog.
-Yes, Deco.
-Deco.
[ Audience "awws" ]
[ Applause ]
These are very --
very attractive photos of deco
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Were these professionally done?
-This was taken
in the House Rules Committee
He was a doggy chairman
of the day.
-Uh-huh.
-He rotates, so there's
a cast of characters,
and so they very graciousl
invite the dogs of many member
to take photos there.
-Oh, this was not
a special treatment for you.
It's a rotating set of dogs.
-Yeah, it's a thing.
So, there's a lot of different
doggy chairs of the day.
-By the way,
I don't know why
that's not on C-SPAN because -
-It should be!
-It should be because C-SPAN
is boring and needs more dogs.
-It would be like Puppy Bowl
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, exactly.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always really nice
to have you on the show.
Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.